[music]
>> Abdullah Yusuf Ali alhamdulillah, he
spent about 40 years
only
in translating
this
particular work of his.
And when a person reads it,
he finds that in the commentary, this
particular translation the advantage is
that it has a commentary which is
neither
too comprehensive,
neither too concise. You have some
masha Allah commentary which are
very
exhaustive. Ibn Kathir alhamdulillah
very good. We'll come to it later on.
So, this is a translation which has a
commentary
which is neither too exhaustive,
neither too concise. It's medium.
So, when a person is reading the
translation,
there are footnotes mentioned
which give more details of a particular
thing. So, it becomes easier for a
layman
who has no knowledge of Islam when he's
reading this, if he wants to know. And
the commentary is such that if a person
who is even a non-Muslim
who has no knowledge of Islam, he will
be able to, if not understand
completely, at least grasp
what is the context
and what
is the translation that has been
presented, what does it mean?
Unlike some translations which are I
don't recommend at all for non-Muslims,
which we'll come to it later on.
But specially in the field of Dawah
I prefer Abdullah Yusuf Ali. One of its
major drawbacks of this translation is
that the English, again, there is
the original work of Abdullah Yusuf Ali.
Then there's a revised edition, then
there is re-revised, and many revisions
have taken place.
As far as the original translation is
concerned
this is the original translation
of Abdullah Yusuf Ali.
And the English in it
is
more of that archaic English.
Or some people call it the biblical
English.
Where the word thou, thee
ye is used. And for people like us it's
difficult.
But let me tell you
Arabic as a language, it is more
specific than any other language.
It's more precise
than any other language in the world
that I know of.
And that is the reason Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala in his divine wisdom chose Arabic
to present his last
and final revelation. In normal English
that we know, suppose I have to say you.
So, you can be used for male
can be used for female.
If it's singular, also it is you.
If it's plural, also it is you.
In Arabic for male
you is different.
Anta. If it's
female it's different.
Anti. If it's singular, it is different.
If it is plural, it is different. If
it's two
it's again different. That means
you in English is used for six words in
Arabic.
If it's feminine
the word is different.
If it's masculine, it's different. Anti
anta.
Then dual
in English language we have singular and
plural. In Arabic, we have singular,
dual, and plural. Plural in Arabic means
more than two.
So if the word you is used in English,
it can be male, female, singular, dual,
plural, all put together. So you have to
decipher which is what.
In Arabic
just by saying one word you can
understand whether it's singular male or
singular feminine or it's dual
male or dual feminine or it is more than
two
female or more than two male.
So in the archaic English
when they used thee
and thou
it to a certain level is much better
than modern English where they use one
word.
So you can come to know
that whether it is singular or plural
unlike the modern English. That's the
reason Abdullah Yusuf Ali went out of
his way though it's difficult for a
normal modern English man to understand,
but if you know this English
you will be able to understand the Quran
more closer. Many a times it makes no
difference to you whether it's male or
female or singular or plural or dual.
But sometimes it makes a difference. So
that is more closer
than
the modern English in which we speak.
So person who's not used to this of
English, it will be a major drawback for
him.
If you can cope with such English, I
would recommend you stick to it. If you
cannot,
there are other revisions which have
converted the thee thou to you.
Easy.
So, some people wrote that they've done
the translation is very good. Okay, let
us convert the difficult part into easy
part because that's not the major forte
of the translation. So, they've
converted it.
And those are available called as
revised
revisions of various types. There were
gross mistakes
in the translation of Abdullah Yusuf
Ali. One of it was that
he wasn't very crystal clear
as far as riba was concerned.
Not that he said it's allowed, but he
left some room
for people to
decipher something else. So, in the
revised edition, the one that I refer
to,
this one,
it's a revised edition done
by the Islamic Institute
in USA.
This is printed by Amana Corporation,
but the research was done by
International Institute of Islamic
Thought. That's IIIT.
Which did the revision, and I believe
it's one of the best revisions
available. Therefore, I prefer referring
to this revision per se.
It's done by IIIT.
International Institute of Islamic
Thought.
This is an organization
in USA, and one time the ex-president
of
the Islamic International University of
Malaysia,
IIUM,
Sheikh Abu Sulayman,
and Sheikh Ahmad Totonji was his person
who used to always be second in charge,
who was also there when he was handling
the International Islamic University of
Malaysia,
and then
he had to shift to USA. So, this work,
mashallah, is done by them.
And even they clarified the print
because the old print of the Rasul Allah
wasn't very legible.
So, I personally refer to this.
Therefore, you find that the green Quran
is there.
And
at one time, when it was released, I had
thousands of copies
of this.
Always people ask me, "Can we have that
Quran?" I said, "There's no magic in
this Quran."
But personally, it is dear to me because
if I take another print,
then the photogenic memory which is
there, what is where, it gets disturbed.
So, I distributed most of the copies. I
had only a limited few copies.
I don't know how many because when I
travel, I always use this. So, this time
I decided that in the last training
program I had many. Now, I had limited,
but then I did a stock checking.
And I decided, "Okay, I can spare
20 copies for you."
So, inshallah, it will be given to you
today, inshallah.
This will be given to you.
There is no magic in this copy.
There's nothing like it is a good omen
and all. We don't believe in that in
Islam. But for me, it has a positive
point. It may not have that same
positive point for you.
So, not that you have to use this, but
if you like it, you can use it from the
stock I have.
I don't know how long will I live,
but I like to show a good copy to the
audience. Few I have kept for myself,
and I could afford
to spare 20. Last lot that I can spare
from the stock that I've got. So,
inshallah, you'll be having this
particular copy.
This particular copy, this particular
print, this particular look.
And this I recommend to a die because it
even has references from the Bible.
Though it's not the best in references
for comparative religion, I'll come to
it later on.
But
it has. And as is the Hadith of Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
it's mentioned in Sahih Bukhari,
Balleghu and me will die, which is a
very famous Hadith.
Propagate even if you know one verse,
but that's not the complete Hadith.
That's part of the first Hadith. The
complete Hadith says that there is no
Hadith.
There's no objection
if you
quote
from the scripture of the people of the
book. But when you quote, you should
realize and check it should not
contradict the Quran.
If anything which contradicts the Quran,
that thing is not authentic.
If it matches with the Quran, we have no
objection in accepting it.
What does not contradict
and does not match, it is mobile
optional. May be right, may be wrong.
As a general rule, keep a point that
anything which contradicts with the
Quran cannot be authentic. Point number
one.
We reject it.
Anything which matches with the Quran,
we accept the matter, not the source.
We accept the matter, not the source.
Suppose the book says that God is one
and same time say no alcohol. So we
accept the God is one is correct. It
matches with the Quran. The book may not
be authentic, but we have no objection
accepting that matter per se.
If anything matches with the Quran,
we as Muslims don't have objection in
agreeing that thing is 100% correct, but
the source totally may not be correct.
Is it clear?
So if a book says God is one,
alhamdulillah. But the book also says
alcohol is allowed, no we don't agree
with
Similarly, anything which contradicts
with the Quran, if a book says there are
two gods, we reject it irrespective from
where it comes.
That matter we reject. And we reject the
authenticity also. There's a difference
between confirmatory test.
So if it's
not correct, we reject the source also
as a whole. But if it's matching, we
don't accept everything.
If it contradicts, we reject the source
completely.
That source is not authentic.
Something else may be right of that
possible. But as a whole, the source is
not authentic. But that same unauthentic
source can even tell you things which
authentic.
Like a book says 2 + 2 = 4 and 3 + 3 =
7. So, 2 + 2 = 4 is correct, but 3 + 3 =
7 is wrong. So, part is correct, part is
wrong. So, when it matches, we say,
"Okay, the matter is correct. The full
source may not be authentic, may be
authentic, Allah knows better."
So, that is the reason there is no harm
in quoting other scriptures besides the
Quran
and Islamic scriptures, but if it
matches, we say the matter is correct
because Quran is the Furqan.
If it contradicts, we reject the source
also.
The source is not fully authentic, but
may contain
parts otherwise. Is it clear?
Like people say, "Why do you quote the
Bible?" Bible, we don't say the word of
God. We'll come to it later on.
But if it matches with the Quran, we
accept this portion as authentic. This
portion, this matter per se. Because
Quran is the Furqan.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Ar-Rahman Ar-
The Rahman